أسفل شارع جانبي في toblesi على الجانب الآخر من
الكنيسة ، توجد حانة تسمى Grail ، وهي
مكان مقدس من نوع ما لتناول الجعة الباردة
، ويقول مالك الحانة فيسنتي أليكسيف ، وهو
روسي ، إنه أجرى
محادثة واحدة خاصة كثيرًا مؤخرًا ،
مرحباً ماذا تفعل هنا  لقد
انتقلت للتو قبل يومين ، لقد انتقلت للتو منذ ثلاثة
أيام ، لذلك هناك الكثير من الروس
يأتون في
نعم ، ولماذا يغادر الناس
لماذا
التقينا بحوالي نصف دزينة من هؤلاء الأشخاص
هنا ، لكن واحدة وقفت أليسا كوزنتسوفا
غادرت روسيا مع زوجها فقط
بعد أيام قليلة من بدء الحرب ، لم يعد بإمكانك
تحملها بعد هذا الغزو ، كان الأمر
بمثابة دافع إضافي ،
كان عليّ فقط أن أترك الفتاة البالغة من العمر 33 عامًا
، والتي كانت منذ فترة طويلة عضوًا
في معارضة روسيا لصالح الديمقراطية ، وهي
تقول: لم تضع
هذه هي.  تم القبض عليها في عام 2016 بينما
كانت تعمل كمراقب مستقل لاستطلاعات
الرأي في مسقط رأسها في روسيا ،
وتقول إن السلطات الموالية لبوتين اتهمتها
بارتكاب انتهاكات غامضة للانتخابات
واحتجزتها رهن الاحتجاز حتى  انتهى
الغزو لكن الغزو كان القشة الأخيرة
لم تعد أليسا تعيش في روسيا الآن في
جورجيا ، فهي تريد أن يعرف الجميع
الجانب الذي تقف فيه ، أحاول فقط
أن أتحمله وأتقدم خطوة وأشير
بقدر ما أستطيع مع العلم الأوكراني
هناك  إنه عرض عام للدعم
يتطابق مع أعلام أوكرانيا في تبليسي التي ترفرف في
كل مكان في جورجيا ، وهي جمهورية سوفيتية سابقة
غزت أيضًا من قبل جيوش بوتين في
عام 2008 ،
كثيرون هنا يتعاطفون بشدة مع
ما يمر به الأوكرانيون ،
لكن الأمر لا يتعلق فقط بالمشاعر المؤيدة لأوكرانيا ،
بل إنها أيضًا مناهضة.  - انظر
إلى باب المقهى هذا يقول لك
أكثر من موضع ترحيب هنا إذا كنت توافق على أن
بوتين مجرم حرب وتحترم
سيادة الدول المسالمة ، من
الواضح تمامًا كيف يشعر أصحاب هذا المتجر
بعلامة أخرى في متجر ليس بعيدًا  يقول
في جزء منه أن بوتين شرير إذا كنت لا
توافق على هذه التصريحات ، من فضلك
لا تأتي في كثير من الروس في جورجيا
يشعرون بنفس الطريقة التي يشعر بها البعض حتى
في الاحتجاجات الأخيرة حيث تم وضع دمية
in كان محترقًا ، لكنهم في بعض الأحيان
يتجمعون مع بوتين وأنصاره
رغم ذلك
وهم يحتسون القهوة في اليوم التالي للقائنا وهم
يشربون من أكواب مزينة
بألوان أوكرانيا ، تقول أليسا أن
سائق سيارة أجرة أخبرها مؤخرًا أنها كانت
واحدة من الطيبين لأن 90  من
الروس يجب أن يُشنقوا ، فليس من الجيد
معرفة
أنك نازيون
عادوا الآن إلى الحانة ، أخبرنا كل روسي
أن الغالبية العظمى من
الجورجيين كانوا لطفاء
ومرحبين وأنهم ممتنون للعيش في
مكان أكثر حرية
لأن الجميع  تحدثنا إليهم أيضًا قالوا
إنهم سيكونون هنا لفترة من الوقت ، أحب
حياتي هناك ،
لكنني لن
أعود إلى هناك في أي وقت قريبًا
مات ريفرز سي إن إن تبليسي جورجيا